what is happening there citizens of the reject
Nation we are going to watch House of the Dragon
episode 6 today John how are you I am nervous and
excited how are you I am excited not nervous I
have utter Faith you know we're doing a time Jump
we're getting some new faces I'm sure it's gonna
be fine it'll be great I have the utmost faith
in this show so do I uh ladies and gentlemen
one thing I want to mention really quick is if
you happen to see those like spam messages going
about of like hey bro you won congratulations it's
happened a lot of YouTube channels I keep blocking
as many of these accounts as possible but they
keep creating new ones please do not respond to
them we've had a few followers who have already
like given out contact information please do not
do it that is not us want to make that clear uh
secondly leave a like because I just uh decided
to look out for you guys yeah so you deserve
a pat on the back in the form of an upvote
yeah leave a like And subscribe and click that
notification Bell to get notified when I react
for the next episode is out leave your thoughts
Down Below on what you think of this particular
one also full interaction watch along as we
sync up with their own copy of House of the
Dragon available for super sexy Rejects at our
patreon page we cover several shows over there
exclusively with reaction highlights and watch
alongs included thank you to all who have joined
us so far your support means the world and lastly
the team of prepper thank you for helping us edit
down these highlights uh yeah I'm excited
let's see what's going on in today's episode
mm-hmm and again
without modern medical practices
so much more unsettling whether successful
or unsuccessful births in this shower
quite unsettling
princess
what a reintroduction yeah what a moment
oh my god oh Christ I'm taking myself a
bed princess yes I should help me dress
so creepy I know I better talk about a Warner a
boy yes hold on oh like no connection oh my God
seleno it is a privilege to be
amongst the first two congratulate you
I may be of any service come my Lord we
got it from here John Malkovich has to
obtain everything I know that's
an impressive ass crane shot
all princess wow yeah you have an age
today what was that conversation last week
nonsense what happy news this
morning he lives just barely
we haven't still free great name yeah I do hope
the labor was easy I think I called the midwife
that's the renyra I know
soon I'll need to make it when he looks like you
I think me before you name my channel he's our
child is he not which means I get to name him
any one of us is bleeding I deserve
some saying the Affairs of my own family
it seems interested in our first right
I was waiting for that
we chose an egg for the baby
that looks like the perfect one
and egg cheese the dragon pit princess I thought
at best there is baby another boy I heard
oh my God it is there baby she
got a thing for her her guards
Young Chris Pratt once they're fully Bound to You
they will refuse to try construction for any other
can I say it
is for Max
that pork you're the only one of
us without the dragon indeed so
we found one for you oh no behold the pink dress
the short amount of carefully
first flight's always rough
he's gonna take that pig and
make it the fiercest in the realm
it's just gonna be a brothel of dragons
just laying eggs all over each other foreign
say the words
I just wanted to meet their eggs over hatched
why is that you know why I'm afraid I don't don't
I had a black mirror at once
one day she escaped her pasture
the neighboring stallion side of fall on her
was born the most unremarkable brown horse
nature is a thing of mysterious works
it's a very viscerous answer I am so
worried about what Allison's gonna do yeah
yeah I'm afraid he will eventually someday
die and it's all gonna come out the princess
raniera is brazen and Relentless a spider who
stings and sucks her prey dry spoiled oh wow God
yes Homeland yeah whose idea is it
the pig was it your plot it was the two of them I
could be sure Emma does your brother oh he said We
are family out the new will Ascend the throne into
Sarah's Targaryen would be her Heir your very life
could be forfeit you are the challenge you are
the challenge aegon simply by living and breathing
yeah you are the King's first born son and what
they know holds everyone in the realm knows
in their blood and in their bones
that one day you will be our King
's scary
all these years Allison's been on the
same same anxiety real riddled mission
God what a curse it was to marry the king
thank you
these guys have just been dealing
with this [__] all these years
permanent residence here in pentos
this Mance I would give to you outright we are
Travelers we've already extended our visit here
Mr Gemma softer when we will suddenly
entertain so they must have really hit it
off after a rainer's wedding oh yeah it's
a good life here welcomed and vetted and
eternally guessed precisely they are using
us it's refreshing isn't it I want my child
to be born where I was born on drift mock at
my end I want to die a dragon Rider's death
just when I thought he got way more vulnerable you
know like we're still here I'm done what are you
stopping your knees feet life
this is the staff lineup my dude
you're turning into the Crypt Keeper
knock down then you get up again
they're never going to keep you down
weapons up boys
boys you mean Sons children of mine
question my method of instructions sir
well I merely suggest that method be applied
to all your people very well I will kill the
Targaryen Lads eldest son against eldest son
it's hardly a fair map I know you've never
seen true Battlestar but when Steelers drawn a
fair match isn't something anyone should expect
okay surprise Kristen still has a job no
I'm surprised he's so chill right now yeah
I'll deal with him this episode's actually
giving me season one Game of Thrones Vibes yeah
he's really playing favorite
this is what you teach Cole
cruelty the weaker opponent your interest in the
Princeton's training is quite unusual Commander
have that kind of devotion toward
a cousin or a brother or a son
don't you're revealing your cards man yeah dude
you gotta gotta be Chiller than that oh damn
Kirsten's getting a taste of his
own medicine from a few years ago
he's so like bitter and angry and envious hey
positively green the son of a steward he is
you have laid US Open the accusations
of an uglier treachery yeah dude you're intimacy
the princess Renee renewable mean Exile and death
for her for the children flimsy Shield alone
stands between you and the headsmen
those babies don't look black at all
I feel like you could have seen
this come I have played my part
here you do not desert your post when
the storm the wise sailor flees the storm
as it Gathers I really love this dialogue
yeah and man is everyone in pain in the show
that's your princess and the heir to the throne
you are commanded to remain in King's Landing
and at my side let's try popping a real one yeah
please there's one real one I feel like you guys
really could have saved yourself so many headaches
some type of witch potion an equivalent to a
Viagra yeah there's got to be something or a way
to you know just turkey baster but if you wish to
wish to be your father would tell you the
same father ignores me he's doing his best
I really like her she's the only one with
like a gracious heart yeah everyone else is
so emotionally retreated now they've all had to
compromise a great cost of their own happiness
that was that was a sick burn perhaps
I too I'm not the wife you would have
wished for yourself Elena that made my piece
the man I married more than this
you two must go to the counseling of
couples next episode Colin a maester
's looking there would be country folk who know
where the lines have been drawn for Generations
that is easy enough
those actresses are really good yeah
it's a really impressive handoff I have felt the
strife between our families of late my queen but
we are one house long before that we were friends
we look like different people back then my son
jacaris will inherit the Iron Throne after me I
propose we betrothed him to your daughter Helena
Ally ourselves
to finally getting along the
Dragon's egg is a handsome gift
I thank you for your offer and we will
consider it Julie you must rest now husband
oh Sarah's just once everyone to get alive
though and it's so terrible at making it happen
we're a family childish corals joined hands and be
stronger for it As You Wish husband when I am cold
in my framing God they are both Relentless
protective and desperate Your Grace I feel
I have come to resign my position as hand of
the king what a man my son howim has disgraced
himself and every fish wife in King's Landing
will soon be telling the Tale But there is a
shadow over my house and it grows ever dark
I can no longer serve you with integrity
yeah I don't know upstanding guy you you
have so much technique such a gluten yes
oh my God Allison Jesus Christ the one thing you
know it you will continue in your service to the
crowd I would then ask leave to take my son from
court and the school came back to the family seat
at parano and will be Lord of Heron's castle
one day it is time he assumed his duties there
oh it's so good so good it's like the
master class Battle of protection and
political war games this is so
good self-interest at all I know
you're playing the old game
man the game is changing
you cannot say my queen that your
father would be would be partial in the
end no but he would be partial to me oh
in order
so theirs is the Hannah here's the his
brother is the one so everyone he was a garden
oh I'm prepared to offer you Mercy if you're
prepared to pay a little price oh what
why why don't show it oh wow oh my God
I I almost closed both of them cut away and you're
just imply I can't not you must put now my lady
it's the limit of my art
child will not come
the child refuses to be born
here couldn't lay open the womb
try to remove the infamous by way of the blade
oh that guys
no
body
oh wow that Dragon really didn't
want to do that yeah man loyal to one
I'll be a stranger when we meet again
damn Kristen you know how to
push all the right buttons
it's a long game of getting back at somebody
never recovered from that [__] in his honor
you are a Targaryen
matches dude Just Say Elena is your your
father it's a dragon stand me I should have
left years ago if you were absent from court
she would pour her honey in your father's age
the wise sailor flees the storms it Gathers
bring him oh we'll need every sword we can master
bring Kieran Culkin along the gay lives on
gay is okay at Dragonstone
Hauser save the cat moment yeah
save my husband's mistress boyfriend
foreign
something's gonna happen to him
oh
my God against his own brother
this world was so cruel
oh that is ridiculous what a treachery Jesus up
oh man dude that other son is
oh steak and a half [__] oh
oh hell's gonna break loose all seven of them
oh this is not gonna fly but I
will surrender what you should know
or they both die
Queen makes away
not seven to the realm would not strive to fulfill
it I assume new world rights to your father oh
she did not uh but that's how he gets you foreign
yeah yeah oh my God what a like they're
all sorted and twisted and there's so many
intersections between personal and political and
everything in between and yet this one felt like
the most the most of all that like Jesus so many
twists of the knife so many people burned alive
I don't trust my family anymore
yeah keep an eye on you're gonna wake up in a
locked room a little bit on fire just any of
them they're always looking out for themselves
kill me in a heartbeat if I meant they could
gain some power I just try to advise you free of
personal gains free of personal self-interest sir
oh my goodness gracious can't trust
anyone and you can't make and you
can't throw anything out there you
don't expect somebody to act upon
that was uh that was depressing as [__] that was
that was like so desolate and desperate and yeah
and just as tense like they they're really good at
like once you get started even the chiller scenes
are still sort of like your shoulders are up and
you're like I don't know I got a bad feeling about
this yeah yeah that was really I was just really
it's like stepping into a void I I think it's so
well constructed there's there's such a power to
the right opening scene I really believe in you
gotta nail that opening scene and especially
for such a Time jump and almost like it just
reframes the construction of like those previous
episodes you know I once or I think I think it
was Vince Gilligan who said there was there was a
some screenwriter once uh talked about actually I
think I heard from Dan Merle who quoting someone
else and I was like oh that's interesting about
um if you're writing a pilot you should um you
know write that pilot and then write the second
episode and that second episode's your pilot and I
was like oh that's actually right that is a great
Revelation it's a great tip it's a fantastic tip
oh my God and then stepping into this I was like
you know in some ways it sort of feels like this
was the first episode yes you know obviously it
wouldn't it wouldn't work as well and you do
need some additional context to really keep up
um but in some ways it does feel
like a first episode to a series
um and then the other ones I love how like this
comes in the middle of it all and then you have
all that other supporting episodes prior to help
Elevate this episode and it it's so strong and I
think this show has such a great grasp on how
to handle the in-between with the time jumps
because all the strained relationships and all
the emotions that have been percolating throughout
that have just been boiling over like you you have
someone like Allison what I love of the parallel
of drama with Allison and renera is like Allison's
so out to get renera like she's so out to get her
standing so many times and we've seen Allison
to send to the the position of Queen through
Power of manipulation you know even though we
witnessed it happen in a way where it didn't
seem like she really wanted it but her father
you know uh manipulated her into doing it to
force her to do it and now that she's here she has
embraced the position of Queen she she is Queen
and more importantly she's a mother
she and she's a very protective mother
and and you got the same thing with renera
and they both just want to protect their
families their me their their media families
you know their their next of kin and stuff
and then that's where so much of this this Mind
Games comes from and trying to take each other
down and stuff but it's like how I I always talk
about like a big part of plotting is you don't
want to just see plot unfold you really want
to see what will happen to characters via the
plot like how will what will become of them what
will change them and I loved how like this whole
episode Allison uh played brilliantly by Olivia
Cook uh like Allison is is just so headstrong and
so determined and just like try to cut through
the [__] and I think that opening scene is
so strong of the way they paint the light like
you're capturing it from rhaenyra's perspective
the show has pretty much put you in renero's
perspective as she is the protagonist of the
show and when she gives birth this struggle and
and then immediately it's this like foreboding
ominous presence of like what is Allison like now
yeah and why does she want to see this baby yeah
what's going on nah she just wants to make sure
she's like ain't black yeah looks nothing like
that guy go back try again I'm not gonna recognize
this air yeah such Mrs butts is a [__] baby
and uh because like like Allison is is frustrating
at the same time I'm like well she's not wrong
yeah she gets to be and the thing that this
shows God of me to become compassionate for
her in an angle because you don't want to see
renero taken down you don't want to see like you
that's the thing you don't want as an audience
member like I don't want to see renera suffer
and yet Allison is not wrong about what
her Pursuit is of the truth she's trying
to expose yeah because she fears for the life of
her children dying yeah where that's all according
to the rules like she has followed suit and she
seems like she's been faithful this entire time
like I was wondering you know does she sleep or
maybe the show will unveil that she she does have
some fun with someone else on the side but the
impression I get is that she abides by the rules
yeah that she follows through and and and it is
like uh it's such it's so well constructed how
none of this is is black and white and I love how
it's just all like just messed up these families
yeah so messed up yeah well you can and you can
feel how and why people act the way they do even
if it hurts or even if you don't you know want
yeah even if you're rooting for one character
or another you can't help but see where each
one is coming from and I thought like Allison
has a really great and fascinating Journey
over this and and all that groundwork they
laid really does hold up because yeah like that
ending beat where she finds out that um that uh
you know the the sun's strong whatever that uh
guy's name is with the cane uh you know when she
finds out Loris there you go yeah she finds out
what he really did and you can tell like oh this
is probably her moment to cross over to the other
side of like oh now I'm in some kind of disastrous
circumstance I didn't ask to be a part of and I'm
now in the game I feel like part of what you get
to watch characters do is is either in indulge in
or abstain The Game of Thrones yeah and so now she
like it or not has been pulled into it despite
her best efforts and it's like those foundations
make so much sense when you see like her father
that last scene she had with him after putting
so much faith in rhaenyra and then you see the way
they interact now Allison and raniera interact and
it's like you can tell that deep deep deep deep
down there's that wish of like you know there's
that Bond we used to have it's somewhere in there
but I just can't trust you anymore I can't put my
faith in you anymore no matter what game you talk
and you can feel the strain of the history of
the characters but also you can really feel the
immediacy like when she has that scene with egg
had a wild scene with aegon where she like
grabs his face and is like no like she might
try and eliminate you like you see the corners
she's been pushed into and I love that one bit
she says because I really felt it for her as
much as you know everybody has their opinion
when she says that thing of like nobody's I don't
have anybody in my corner like nobody is lying on
my behalf nobody is is you know at least taking
what I have to say seriously and I really felt
that for her I was like I get it you know you're
in a very thankfulness position and you're pretty
much doing it alone you know she is doing it
alone yeah like she doesn't have the support
of her husband not at all not at all he's like I
just want to get along that's definitely uh that's
definitely the right child all three all those
kids and you feel like I don't see the black and
I feel like so much it it creates a fascinating
scenario because I'm like I don't even think king
viserys would need to do like the full-on letter
of the law because everybody you know like part
of the charm of of these shows and part of the
truth of the matter is everybody stands on the
ceremony even though everybody knows that to
some degree or another the ceremony is [__]
and built on lies and uh and and uh yeah I don't
know there's there's I I lost my train of thought
ceremony train of Lies yeah you know it's it's
it's that thing of oh yeah if visiris had even
just I don't know had a straight talk with her
I feel like so much trouble could be averted
but it's his like staunch adherence to nah I
like he he plays the willful ignorance really
well because you can tell he knows the truth
and you can also see him creating lies for
himself to believe and then pass office well
he has to believe it because if he does if he
doesn't believe it that's condemnation for
his daughter yeah he has to Exile and kill
her because it's not like she just gets you
know she doesn't just get in trouble she's
dead yeah and then in a day he does love
her this so yeah that's uh I I love the I
love the dejected nature of every every character
portrait here because everyone's so retreated and
has to live under a guise like all elephant
wants like personally my favorite performance
in this episode was was Olivia Cook I thought she
was very gripping yeah and because she's so on
edge and it's just such a desperation for truth
and I do think who's playing Emma Dar I got her
name eleven Darcy I'm a Darcy Darcy fantastic so
internal yeah and I I love a good in um I love a
good performance where you you have to it's very
physical and you have to keep it together there's
a truth underneath the surface but you can't let
on like that whole beautiful shot where she's
she it's the after birth um uh situation she's
got going on and she's trying to walk through
the halls and and demonstrate character and
strength and be protective of her newborn
and she's gotta like just not leave the portrayal
of blood in it but also not look like She's
suffering here and has to it has to be strong
and every scene she has there's so much going
on underneath her dialogue there's and the the
reactions that she's having towards um oh my God
totally blank on his name there's a lot of names
here people what is the name of of the the husband
who's oh Elena lanor um uh like every moment
with lane or and then lanor has just escaped into
uh a life of just he's just it's just pure
escapism for the guy debauchery having fun messing
around partying he's like a college kid who can't
get in touch with his emotions you know yeah like
a dude who just went through the worst heartbreak
fight man yeah it's like I love that the last
episode was that that Dreadful wedding moment
where they where everything fell apart for them
and truths for truths have been coming out like
people know the truth but no but it's just not
public knowledge right now and or something that
we can't no one can just talk about then you've
you catch up to here and you watch how everyone's
changed since that moment in time like Kristen is
so angry like he was such a sweetheart he was
so sweet he was like the gentlest spirit and
then here he's so Allison and wants revenge like
you said playing the long game it it doesn't even
it's like he doesn't strike when he's a character
who's who would say I I'm seeking Revenge but it's
going to be coming out in all the most bitter
envious ways Possible Oh yeah and that whole
taunting and using the children as a way to ring
out the truth uh from uh oh my god oh from uh
uh Harwin Harwin straw break bones yeah from
Harwin was was such a powerful scene because
it's they're using the kids are the truth to
the whole situation yeah and and nothing is more
um evoke something so Primal and nothing speaks
more volumes of Truth than than the defense
of nature one two you get to watch him play a
mirror almost to like moments he's had in the
past it's like he has that moment with Allison
where he's just like the guilt is too much I
need to say something you know like he reveals
himself and he basically lures Harwin into the
same kind of situation and then combines it with
his little wedding display it's just like yeah
man you know now you know how I feel you know
break it and wail on me for a minute and then
yeah expose yourself like play right into
my trap and then Damon is a character who
you know you when you meet this character
he's someone who who seemed to want it all
like he wanted it all and he's hidden away from
a lot of those desires now it's uh it's obviously
there but it's it's it's like this coldness has
brewed over him which is also allowed again for
this great fleshing out of character of you know
it's it's kind of like those movies where you you
got that and that badass past character kind
of like uh I don't know I don't know why this
is the one that comes to Mike it's not the best
representation but decently apt uh Bob odenker now
[__] nobody okay that's the kind of character is
like I got a badass pass and yeah I've had to push
it away and and I like my family yeah but there's
there is this other urge inside of me but I I have
to hide from it and even though he hides from it
it's it's led to would look like a relationship
where he actually did love her sure and and the
that ugliness still managed to to um uh give me a
word John uh to emerge and yeah resurface trying
to think of a word as like grows like a virus
yeah yeah I guess that works yeah like the seat
back and it will relax into it ugliness will over
overtakes a situation again and then led to the
death of her in a way that was so emote because
I really liked her and she was the one with the
most heart uh the mom I was gonna say this was the
episode where the two characters who demonstrated
the most like genuine either hearts or just like
uh non-self-interested honor both got flamed
yeah in this episode everyone's so many like
little fingers here I know everyone's a everyone's
amateur little finger Everyone's an amateur little
fingers a lot of against each other because yeah
you had this strong it's interesting how you have
um uh who was the okay there's Lionel there's
Laris and who's the who's the dad uh the hand
yeah yeah yeah yeah uh where is he fine no no
no no no it is Lionel Harwin yes yeah the city
watch and then yeah Laris is is the uh conniving
because lionels seems to uphold the most integrity
and and then you have um Harwin who doesn't seem
like a bad guy like this is like a bad guy at
all but he does not follow through with the rules
and is committing an act that could lead to some
terrible things and you gotta Learners who's
just like Sneezy and conniving yeah yeah it's
easy slimy yeah he and it just hit me that that's
the conversation that viserys has with Lionel like
a few episodes back when he steps up to him and
the series is all drunk he's like I bet you want
to marry my daughter off to Sir break bones your
son blah blah blah he's like fancy idea but no sir
and and sure enough it essentially happened even
though it's not really of his design and then it
leads to his death like that's a great portent
like a great ironic foreshadowing yeah ugh but
yeah uh I feel like what they do with Damon is is
fascinating because you expect such a you expect
him to be almost like a Joffrey at the outset just
because he has this sort of wild and that's aegon
soon enough yeah but uh I don't know he comes in
with this very sort of almost amoral just like
I don't know he could do anything at any time
kind of feral energy and now to watch him as he
is kind of like the most simmered down version of
that you're like you can tell that that impulsive
guy is still in there but as you yeah contemplate
just like settling down and getting fat and then
also you know I love the the unspoken notes like I
feel like so much of his actual character is never
in the dialogue because like their connection
kind of fascinated me there like it and and to
draw contrast from like the first episode where
it's like the series has the back and forth with
himself about like what do I do do I cut the
baby out does the mom like you know uh and
then to watch Damon have to go through that here
but it felt so different and it does feel like he
cares and just can't communicate that truly yeah
like and uh yeah like the way he he stumbles to
the beach just in time to watch her you know
be incinerated with their unborn child like
I didn't even know her then it was getting me so
emotional it was such a powerful moment and I was
tearing up at at that moment it's so powerful and
it like there's something very uh connective and
I think relatable of that feeling of like I'm
asking your own pet to murder you yeah to put
you out of here like this is the way I gotta go
well like she said she said when she died how'd
she say she wanted to die I was a battlefield or
by fire I figured she's a dragon Rider's death
Dragon Rider's death yeah yeah and and just like
the way they animated the dragon in that moment
of just this like I don't you could feel what the
dragon's thinking like I don't understand no yeah
but I can't you're the only person I I answer to
you're my bonded writer I can't do that yeah yeah
and and she's just pleading for it to happen
Damon I feel like the new Trope of Damon is
he's gonna have a well uh wife or something who
shows up one episode you're like man I really
like you you're you're interested Oh no you're
dead now yeah you're gone but like it was so
heartbreaking because yeah they they have that
whole debate which felt very real of like no I
I want you know I want our new next child to be
born you know in the house of my father I want
the kids to grow up there I want them to to know
their Birthright and now like all of that goes up
in Flames like literally yeah it's like it's it's
heart it's heartbreaking and it also I don't know
and she also knows him well yeah it seems though
like you can pick he's he's defensive because
she's she's prodding at truths you know of this
guy who who is he's denying what he really wants
but then he indulges himself with reading about
the Legacy Dragon Riders and stuff the the kind
you know he fancied himself to to to ascend to
yeah and he he blocks it because it kind of get
it because you know like back home it's [__]
nightmares this whole this whole business is is
such a horrible situation for everyone no matter
what rung of the ladder you're on yeah that's the
main lesson I learned from this show is never be
involved in ruling in statecraft because it's just
gonna destroy your life and your morality and your
morale again what I really liking about this show
especially with like historical fantasy pieces
it's usually like good versus evil or there's an
outside force that threatens our main characters
or uh you know and in some ways uh like like even
with the crab king crab king crab feeder feeder
crab king is SpongeBob uh with the crap feeder
um but the craft feeder at the offset it was
seeming for people who haven't read the book
it was seeming like okay this is the big bad or
something like this is the this is the threat to
targaryens uh and and no they they do away with
that and again the threat is everything internal
everything is like it's the thing that is going to
bring a crumbling to the legacy is not and maybe
I'm wrong but this is the way the show seems to
be painting it is that it's gonna be all within
and not not because people attacked it we're like
we're taking King's Landing yeah yeah no it's all
just lies and truths placed in in inopportune and
opportune places yeah you're just watching yeah as
as lies get worse and truths come at inappropriate
or uh not inappropriate I guess there's never
bad time for truth but yeah I feel like
horrifically inopportune moments and it's it's
really uh the journey that I mentioned again
what I brought at the beginning of this talk
was like the plot is so interesting to unfold but
I'm so intrigued to see like what dark depths are
characters like Allison and renera gonna descend
to as the more this goes on I'm so worried about
both because there's a thing with Allison like
as Disturbed as she is by the revelation of the
truth of what happened to the strongs uh it's and
I like to some symbolism of the strongest but but
but the how Disturbed she was by that Revelation
you're like who's only gonna get worse for you man
you're gonna have to do worship yeah you're
gonna be happy to learn about this piece of
information you're going to turn into Lady
Macbeth yeah because I mean now now you've
got blood on your own hands and now you can't you
know cling to the fact that you've always tried
to you know do everything by the book and stand
on the ceremonies and you have I forgot his name
again I'm John I'm sorry what's the husband's
name lanor Lenore with Lenor he I you I worry
about the way he behaves because he seems to lack
such because as much has been like I'm committed
I've done everything for my 10-year plan I'm owed
there seems to be this he's going to slip up and
he's going to get himself caught and exposed and
you know yeah he doesn't seem like he lays low or
or does anything with any level of secrecy yeah
there's a bit of this childish quality to him
yeah yeah that remains yeah he he kind of has an
entitled sort of obliviousness not like a devious
um uh borderline maniacal nature in the way
of how Damon is no quite the opposite you know
you're like no you're gonna like slip up and do
something that's going to get you all in trouble
you're gonna get caught you're you're not helping
the situation and it's not this isn't a gripe but
I do want to ring both their necks like guys you
you there must have been a way for you guys to at
least have one child together at least you had to
know this was gonna turn into a complete disaster
I thought that's what they were gonna do I thought
that's what they were I think that's why I was
like wait you gotta have a kid I guess I can just
force it nothing oh sure I mean I'm I'm sure there
are plenty of you know throughout history there
are probably plenty of of men who are forced into
you know hetero marriages and had kids you know
it's definitely possible but yeah I was like I'm
sitting here going man I feel like you guys
could have been a little smarter about this
like I feel like you could again have a couple
bastards but but get one yeah they just needed
one because also too like you know no you're in
the position where it's like of course people
are going to notice unfortunately because
you know you are of such different lineage
well there's a whole plot line
about it in my Me Myself and I were
it's good that's what they
probably Drew inspiration for epic
that's why it's so funny yeah have you seen that
movie uh not in its entirety now I've seen a
couple of the very very well-known moments his
wife cheats on him okay in the beginning with a
black guy oh no and gives birth to like triplets
before like they're all like completely black
and he just doesn't register like that's not his
kids of course yes yes yes of course I like it
I'm like let's come on it's so obvious look there
look at all that's gonna be the problem it's the
biggest dead giveaway I was like if we one thing
if they were white and maybe you could get away
with some [__] but the fact that like uh the
eyes look off or something but I'm like no no I
mean there's a whole other aspect to this that we
are not talking about yeah mixed race babies are
are yeah you could they're mixed race babies you
could tell when that's happened I'm surprised I
don't even say that in the show I know I'm like
maybe in the book I I don't know if in the book
If the characters are um uh like black folks
I don't know yeah is there like another word
before black people back then I I don't know
that's not a racist word but an actual like
historical work or something yeah yeah yeah
some uh George RR Martin word uh Africa so
but anyway yeah I I would be I'm surprised I don't
no one's bringing up the skin tone I'm like that's
the biggest dead giveaway guys I mean yeah they
have that whole horse horse's conversation and
even that right yeah I was like dude but Sarah's
I appreciate you and we probably didn't know as
much about animals at the time but it's not quite
the same you know like like yeah and like you can
have a cat give a litter and all the lit all
the cats are different colors and [__] but
like I don't know it's a little different when
you got two humans and you do your little Jean
splicing tic-tac-toe there's a skit to be made
about this whole discussion James Corden Bring
It On do it make it happen Gordon get a wig
in some costumes and do it but yeah man this
player is just so white that it overshadows yeah
that's why they have to spoon that hair yeah
or yeah like canceling it out straight brown hair
that's the I guess the deadest giveaway is they're
both so blonde yeah and neither none of their kids
they're both really blunted and it's so true and
it seems like in the Targaryen Clan you know the
the the blonde hair jeans are usually blonde is a
recessive gene scientifically but in the Targaryen
and the Valero Valerian you know lineage it seems
pretty dominant yeah yeah well I mean even Allison
is the she's a Hightower right Allison Hightower
yeah and she she's brunette and uh her kids are
are way blonde yeah they're not even like dirty
blonde are just as Blonde as they get there I do
speaking of light right there like like you've got
so much working against you guys and at least even
if you weren't smart on the first kid at least by
the second one be like we need a blonde baby at
least a blonde baby it would be nice if the baby
was also a mixed race racial background because
then that would be the yeah I could totally
like I've seen it where like we we know um the
Henry's yeah you know like that everyone kind of
had like they they were all like dark olive skin
brown hair brown eyes and then there's David
and like blue eyes and he's like I don't know
this happened but it is but three in a row with
these guys three in a row they all look pretty
similar to each other yeah that's why that's
why uh Damon's just like blunt I'm sarcasm line
yeah because the king pointed out how it looks
a lot like Harwin straw this is so funny he's just
like yeah they do oh it hurts so bad even the kids
can pick up on it even Damon knows that he ain't
been back in Forever yeah oh and that's the thing
I don't know that that's that's the fascinating
part is yeah watching all of this structure and
then watching Everybody Talk the truth underneath
it you know yeah man well yeah it's great [__]
um you can talk forever about this thank
you all for being here um be sure to uh
leave your thoughts down below and let's send
this with shout out some patrons thank you all
Zachary Barker you're sharper Irfan Chow jury Yuri
my type I you're cool I like you Taki wakimaki Ian
Neil Simon's California sweets song High Glover
you're made of rubber Jacob Neptune your gold
like doubloons NMB you're so silly it never
stops with fan Pops I pick up my phone when
it rings from Alan Ling Logan profile pic looks
kind of like Barry kogan Burton no need to fear
you Akira I am drawn to aircons 39 times over
KUSI KUSI you make my my cheek so Mushy Mushy
bear in the garage you're a flare amid the barrage
of you stand out I create a hex around my heart
for Nick X Juan Longoria Never Gonna bore ya you
never make me feel like I fail when I hang out
with Miss Ferguson AKA Gail you're such a haughty
Muhammad al-sharani Jaren wanner you're as strong
as Bruce Banner Cliff Rodriguez better do what
he says it's gonna be okay when you're around
Alex Day master tenebrae movie title John
the goat makes me feel warm like a big hot
coat always a slam dunk when you're playing with
Andy Funk Lorenzo Baxter pump it faster the rain
in Spain falls differently saying on the plane
don't ever try to kill Marco tunn still I never
have to force myself to want to hang out with
Lauren American Horse there's a rhyme in there
somewhere if you find it my home was raided
by simply faded with my mom he corroborated
Ooey the things you do to me Joanna St Louis
he he there's a smell in the debris I think
it's Rogue Cree sour jellyfish 94. don't get
me started on all the farting by Justin Martin
Rosie never nosy Beatty no Haiti calling you got
me bawling when I see you hanging out with Joseph
Stalin Philip Jughead Smith Jr I feel my body's
with when I see Gents Smith because she's so in
shape and it makes me feel fat by comparison
honk honk for Melanie LeBlanc if you support
Melanie we support you TJ track US with uh
habakkus habakkus definitely it's a sauce yeah
I love a good TJ habakkuk sauce anyway guys thanks
so much for being part of our patreon page and uh
your support is undeniable because it's there's
evidence it's here yeah it's evidence so thank you